i want to get another read all of that
this idea of elizabeth warren maybe as a
treasury
secretary the same week we got news that
in the third quarter the economy
zoomed at 33 plus percent now of course
it fell alike amount in the second
quarter nevertheless the comeback
appears to be real
so steve moore um what do you make first
off
of the talk of elizabeth warren as a
treasury secretary
in in in abiding administration well i
think it's an indication of just how
left wing a biden administration would
be i mean elizabeth warren is
very hostile to business interests in
america i think she would be
terrible for the stock market but i
think the more important point
neil is what you just said that my
goodness and you and i've been in this
business a long time
of following these economic statistics i
mean can you think of a stronger closing
statement
for donald trump than those numbers that
came out on thursday
uh you know 33 percent growth most
people don't follow this stuff as
closely as you and i do
you know usually three four five percent
growth is considered a good number
and we got this 33 growth and don't
forget also
neil on thursday morning you know really
good numbers on the unemployment uh with
a
another big drop in the number of people
on unemployment insurance claims
uh we've had something like 11.5 million
jobs created since uh since june so
those are that's a very strong number if
i were trump i'd say look
we're riding on the back of secretariat
here right right now you don't want to
you want to change horses
but you know there are a lot of people
who i guess it depends on their view of
the horses
because 22.7 billion americans are still
claiming some sort of unemployment
benefit as you know steve
and a good many of them maybe close to a
third
uh are exhausting those benefits they'll
run out in in a matter of weeks
so for those people that doesn't sound
like rounding them
that doesn't sound like an economy on
fire and i'm wondering when the
president
pounds that theme but when he pounds
that theme in battleground states
i'm sure that's the president for you
now but when when
does it does it fall on empty ears do
people hear that and say
just like when he says that you know
we're rounding the bend on the on covid
we're not and and when everything's
hunky-dory on the economy
it's not you know it's weird but
certainly i'm not saying and donald
trump isn't saying that
everything's hunky-dory with the economy
it's just that we this is the fastest
recovery
we've ever seen in this country and by
the way it's much faster than any other
european country
you look at those projections neil that
the federal reserve bank made that the
congressional budget office they they
said we'd be lucky we had 12 13 14
growth and here we are at 33 growth they
said
that we'd probably still have 15 16
unemployment rate
we we're now down below 8 so of course
you're right there's still a lot of
problems in this country a lot of heavy
lifting to do to fix the economy
the real question right now for voters
is who do you actually think could do a
better job getting those
you know 10 million jobs back that we
still haven't received but
nobody expected this kind of boom that
we've seen in terms of recovery
uh it really is pretty spectacular by
the way look at manufacturing look at
the construction
uh you cover it every day on your show
neil look what's happening with the
housing market those are really strong
markets right now
um you know the market had a rough week
um it's had a rough month
it's a second down month one of the
worst weeks before an election
we've ever experienced normally not good
for the party in power
are you worried for the president you
mean in terms of the stock market or
yeah yeah well look i i think the stock
market is weak because of what you just
had that we've
seen increasing covet cases but you know
i think that we're seeing better
treatments we're seeing
uh you know people who are being
hospitalized are actually not getting
you know the death rate is falling so of
course you know this is a this is a
two issues i think are at the top of the
mind of voters number one who can get us
through this
this uh this you know terrible economic
time and i think you know most voters
agree that it's donald trump
but then there's also this question
about who is going to deal with this
health crisis and we have
parallel concerns right now but i do
think
you know i think it was bill clinton who
said it's the economy stupid and if it's
the economy that people are voting on
i feel very strongly trump is going to
win in those states like michigan and
pennsylvania where
by the way one last thing look at where
the where the
recovery has been neil it's been in the
southern states it's in texas it's in
tennessee it's in florida
it's in states like utah idaho where are
these
all right steve we shall see thank you
very much